for a male to have the same level of
impulse control as a 10 year old girl
they need to be 24. the doctor I've
heard is two years but even if you think
about two years if you have two 18 year
old people applying to college basically
the 18 year old is competing against a
16 year old imagine you're in 10th Grade
applying to college and all the girls
are in 12th grade that's what we're
facing right now at NYU I can tell you
that some of the schools there if they
were totally applicant blind it would
not only be predominantly female they'd
be 70 Asian female the Asian Community
has been so successful in our society as
it comes to producing traits and
behaviors that colleges love we level
the playing field about an education and
what we found is women just absolutely
blew by yeah man and you think well
what's the problem with that well when
it was 40 60 female to male we decided
to do something about it with Title IX
and affirmative action and we leveled up
women now that it's 40 60 or you could
even argue 3366 in terms of graduation
because men drop out the question is
well are we concerned now